all of this
was a major adversary of the united
states the adversary of the united
states so the angle has been warning
about this for months
and over the weekend the wall street
journal
put it the most starkly ever
chinese ownership of u.s farmland left
more than 20-fold in just one decade
from 81 million dollars in 2010 to 1.8
billion in 2020. beijing hasn't outlined
a strategy but large-scale state backing
for these investments indicates there is
one joining me now are the authors two
authors of that piece both from the
lincoln network lars eric shonander
is a policy technologist and jeffrey
kane is a senior fellow lars
how long has it been since our own
government has audited carefully audited
these purchases so the last time the
program that met tracks these
investments has been audited was in
1989 according to the jao so
ever since then there has been no formal
audit of a program jeffrey how is this
possible you have the ccp
approving these purchases clearly
because no one's going to buy this
without approval from the ccp and yet
this is just like we're just going along
though this is fine tell us the worst of
the worst here well the worst of the
worst is that the ccp is buying through
private companies in china uh massive
tracts of lands of land many acres of
land that are right near military bases
so there's one example in north dakota
another one in texas
it truly is a wild situation to see
chinese companies openly buying land in
where they can spy on american military
bases can we do that in china no it's
not allowed so we're not allowed to do
any of this in china but they can come
here and buy whatever they want china is
a communist country and people cannot
own land the state owns land we can't go
there we can't buy land open a factory
on that land but chinese companies are
free to come here this place is open now
lars smithfield foods website addressed
concerns of their own ties to china they
claim they're not a chinese state-owned
enterprise they don't undertake
commercial activities on behalf
of the chinese government lars it's
understandable why they do that but i
point out but it's very strange that
when the deal came through in 2013 the
company that bought out smithfield foods
wh group was given a four billion dollar
loan by the bank of china a state-backed
chinese bank deduced that loan
that's often considered very strange
that they're being fronted the money to
buy by our largest pork producer but
can't we just get to the cut to the
chase here nothing that chinese
interests do in the united states is not
approved by the ccp in some way shape or
form correct right uh
so the ccp is buying land i'm sorry i'm
just gonna you guys are real academic
i'm gonna say it the way regular people
talk the ccp is approving every single
purchase that's made in the united
states yeah one way or another in one
way or another because because well in
america we have separation of private
business and government we have liberty
we have freedom in china that doesn't
exist private companies are ultimately
accountable and must answer to the
chinese communist party there's no way
around that and if they're buying land
by a military base that is open to abuse
it's open to spying that is a major red
flag and i don't know how this situation
happened but it is absolutely oh my god
i mean they shouldn't be able to buy
anything here oh yeah they have millions
of people enslaved in in labor camps and
we're welcoming here i
last month um adam mentor bloomberg
wrote a piece
implying that the chinese investment in
u.s farmland to ban that would be a
national security or food security issue
for us he also went on to say
it was racist it's a bloomberg writer
racist
to ban china i guess the
libertarians think this is all open
markets open borders they're still
peddling that nonsense
um your reaction to that lars well there
were concerns about that by grace meng
in a different bill a few months ago but
the boring response to that is that
there's other adversaries that haven't
raised concerns about that from north
korea russia venezuela isn't just a
chinese thing it just
any country that's an adversary of the
united states should be shown the door
roughly 40 percent of u.s domestic
farmland will be transferred to new
ownership it said in these and i mean
this is just
this is crazy and jeff and and lars um
i'll go to jeffrey on this it just
mentions but last year congressman
newhouse added this amendment to the
agriculture spending bill that would ban
agriculture purchases from chinese
parties democrat congresswoman grace
mang as you noted strongly opposed the
amendment listen to her logic everyone
has to hear that i understand the issue
and the concerns and the intentions
behind it but i am also concerned about
singling out china and the repercussions
that it will have on the health and
safety of asian americans here in the
united states
jeffrey this is one of the major red
flags of the democratic left they say
that worrying about our national
security against the most authoritarian
police state in the world which is china
is going to be conflated with racism
against asian americans these are
separate issues we can we can we can
promote equality at home we can you know
promote the rights of minorities it's a
fake issue it's a it's a fake issue we
can also uh
fight china we can defend against
chinese incursions
china chinese communist party incursions
into the country these are separate you
know what this reminds me of the wuhan
lab like you could never talk about the
wuhan lab and the origins of virus
because that's racist
it's a total non-sequitur but they throw
sand in the wind and hope you can't see
anything guys great to see you tonight
thanks laura hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else